Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Du immer mehr Leute fragen uns wie sie für logbuch-netzpolitik spenden können.
Ja ja ja die Zahl aber nicht an die Metaebene sondern an einem gemeinnützigen Verein das musst Du erklären Verein.
Naja das dass das habe ich schon vorher erklärt.
Du musst erklären dass das nicht an den Rechnungshof geht.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 302 ordentl wir schreiben den 26.Mai 2019 das ist der Tag der Europawahl also während wir hier aufnehmen seid ihr gerade fleißig am Stimme ab
Tim hoffen wir doch zumindest und ja ich habe die Briefwahl Optionen ziehen müssen leider.
In in einem der Länder ich dachte du hast doch hier Lufthansa 3 Städtereise gemacht Barcelona London Berlin.
Das Triple BWL Birmingham Berlin oder so.
Ich habe ich habe ich habe mich entschlossen in Deutschland meine Stimme abzugeben.
Also das ist einfacher dass du du bist einfach ein ambitionz loser Demokrat.
So siehts aus vollkommen Kautionsfrei.
Hättest du Firma gegründet dann hättest Du nämlich die ganzen Aufträge bekommen.
Noch nicht mal richtig bescheißen.
Ist das Problem der Linken alle viel zu ehrlich wenn das so wird das nie was mit der Politik kann leider nichts gegen tun.
Ja wir wir wir versuchen uns heute kurz zu fassen damit wir auch noch wählen können für Wahlempfehlung ist es halt sein dass ich also ja du hast es schon ja kommt zum einen kann.
Okay ich wollte dir das mal.
Wellen ist geil das nicht selbst noch nicht zweimal wollen Sonne man kann auch direkt wieder.
Ja du bist ja leider nicht du bist ja nicht auf der Liste die du dich für dich auch zweimal wählen.
Ja ich bin nicht auf der Liste ich sage auch nicht wenn ich wenig weiß ich sag nur wenn ich nicht wähle.
Du bist aber eine lange Liste.
Ich ich habe im Internet gesehen CDU soll man nicht wählen AFD soll man nicht wählen SPD soll man nicht wählen aber dazu kommen wir gleich wir machen nämlich wie letztes Mal auch schon versucht mir eine Themenübersicht wir sprechen heute über das.
Verschlüsselungs Verbot dann lachen wir über das Strache video.
Dann gibt's Neues von vom Bürgerkrieg gegen die Fusion.
Und natürlich das Thema um dass keiner herum kommt derzeit wieder diskutieren das wie sagt man rezo Video rezo.
Ich glaube wieso ich bin ja ich bin ja so ein Leser deswegen lese ich auch immer Rezzo,
aber ich glaube der heißt der DDR wenn man spricht ist sowieso aus Riesa.
Wieso na gut dann soll es so sein.
Und lange erwartet jetzt im in im Internet
die logbuch-netzpolitik Shirts sind sofort ab sofort erhältlich bzw bald nicht mehr,
denn nachdem ist auf Twitter Verbreitung fand wurden schon Friede bestellt und einige Größen sind jetzt glaube ich sogar schon der neigen Abzw ausverkauft.
Ja bei den Damen ist es schon etwas eng.
Bei den Damen ausgelacht.
Ja bei den Damen und bei der Übergrößen also von daher.
Das ist also der Herrschaften.
Naja also kann ich mit leben.
Ich auch ich fühle mich sehr gut mit unserer Hörerschaft
und es gab also der Link befindet sich in den schon Ort der Vertrieb findet statt durch den ach je Verlag der von Stefan Urbach betrieben wird der ja auch vor einigen sendung zu Gast war.
Und auch bei den logbuch-netzpolitik Live-Events immer helfend zur Seite steht und bei dem wir uns herzlich dafür bedanken außerdem war noch eine Frage glaube ich per E-Mail oder den Kommentaren,
was für eine T-Shirt es sich denn handele das ist ein
Jersey T-Shirt in schwarz aus 100% Baumwolle 165g pro Quadratmeter Fair Wear
und ich glaube Bio steht auch noch drauf die Farbe ist plastisolfarbe nach Öko-Tex Standard 100 Klasse 1 auch für babytextilien geeignet das T-Shirt ist aber zu groß für ein Baby ich habe es ausprobiert,
und ersetzt das Kleid city,
bedrückt im Berliner Mittelstand.
Ich kann es ist mir schwer gelungen noch fairer und nachhaltiger und besser zu produzieren als so deswegen freuen uns.
Bitte diese und bedruckt ne, glaube ich auch gesagt Klarlack mit Glitzer auf schwarz es ist ein Traum ich finde sie super.
Genau und wenn er ist schon beim Stefan in dem Shop rumstochern soll mal rum gucken Geräusche Bücher am Start also Win-Win-Situation für euch.
Ja relativ viele Veröffentlichungen auch schon und Autorinnen.
Ja ist fleißig auf jeden Fall komme zum ersten Thema ich muss selber feststellen als die Nachricht gelesen habe dass mein erster Gedanke war was der ist immer noch Innenminister.
Mein mein erster Gedanke bei der Nachricht war schon wieder wir sind in einem Zeitloch weil dass es kommt ja die Themen kommen ja immer wieder aufnehmen.
Ja genau diesem Fall,
nicht weniger als die Forderung nach Totalüberwachung,
sind Ministerium scheint begriffen zu haben dass sie da.
Begehrlichkeiten entwickelt haben nach messenger in Diensten,
ist ja nun mal so dass das Überwachen des Internets früher ein bisschen einfacher war weil ich soviel verschlüsselt war das hat sich jetzt schlagartig geändert in den letzten Jahren weil eigentlich,
alle populären Messenger-Dienste heutzutage mit einer Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung Verben man kann davon ausgehen dass die meisten sie auch haben
aber nicht allen so hundertprozentig sicher ob wirklich dasselbe ist was auf der Box draußen draufsteht
aber es ist durchaus so dass man eben heutzutage mit Messengern die ja auch populärer sind deutlich populärer als aber mal E-Mail oder andere alte Kommunikationsformen.
Hatte Dich der security level doch deutlich angestiegen ist sprich hier ist Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung am Start wie wir sie ja eigentlich für alles fordern und das.
Gefällt den Polizeibehörden nicht die halt gerne überall mal rein horchen wollen und da gibt es sicherlich auch hier und da ein berechtigtes Interesse nur.
Die bisherige Lösung die ja vorgeschlagen wurde die Quellen-TKÜ soll nun auf einmal nicht mehr ausreichen die ist ja auch für sich genommen problematisch das hat man ja oft gesprochen
hier wäre ja dann die Installation von,
Malware Spyware erforderlich quasi die Aushebelung der Sicherheit des eigenen Gerätes und dann quasi am Ende da wo es daneben schon entschlüsselt ist.
Der Daten habhaft zu werden
scheint wohl nicht so gut zu funktionieren aufjedenfall möchte Herr Seehofer dass all diese ganzen Dienste jetzt gezwungen werden entsprechende Schnittstellen bereitzustellen sodass Sie auf Anfrage unverschlüsselte Mitschnitte von chat.
Bereitstellen können müssen.
Ist so alt.
Neue neue ist das jetzt nicht ne.
Nein aber das ist so also das ist ja auch so viele hundert tausend mal diskutiert worden ja also seit es Verschlüsselung gibt.
Versuchen starten irgendwie dagegen vorzugehen und ich würde schon.
Contax noch mal kurz herstellen diese ganzen messenger sind verschlüsselt mehr oder weniger oder die es gibt die.
Die versteh messenger wurden verschlüsselt bzw verschlüsselte Messenger wurden populär ungefähr nach diesen Snowden Sachen ja wir wissen facebook hatte damals whatsapp,
kurz davor gekauft für ich glaube 19 Milliarden US-Dollar ja und haben dann irgendwie kurz nach dieses Norden Dingern gesagt ok zack
Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung obendrauf war alle nur so dachte nur krass Facebook alle re
dass das zeigt ja echt mal wie wichtig Metadaten euch sind und das ist euch um Inhalte gar nicht mehr so genau an ankommt es hat aber auch Verein damals denn dieser paradoxisch Treppenwitz der Geschichte war das in dem Moment WhatsApp sicherer war als
De-Mail weil De-Mail ja diesen rechtssicheren Verkehr für jedermann schaffen wollte.
Und hat sehr große Kapriolen geschlagen wurden um in in dieser Implementierung eine sogenannte G10 Schnittstelle
einzurichten ja G10 ist,
die haben wir glaube ich auch mit Klaus Landefeld viel darüber gesprochen bei der lp300 ist eben das wo das.
Grundgesetz Artikel 10 außer Kraft gesetzt wird diese Schnittstelle nennt man dann G10 Schnittstelle was ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig ist.
Also wo wo die die das Geheimnis der Kommunikation eben kaputt gemacht wird und Abhören möglich ist und wir haben.
Auch alle glaube ich
festgestellt dass dieses De-Mail sich in genau deshalb nicht umgesetzt nicht durchgesetzt hat weil hier wieder Kompromisse gemacht wurden in der Sicherheit und ich habe kurz kürzlich auf einer Podiumsdiskussion
mal gesagt wärst du wenn du bei der Sicherheit einen Kompromiss nach dem anderen machst Kompromiss Kompromiss Kompromiss dann steht eben am Ende auch der Kompromiss und dann ist dein System eben im Arsch ja und genau deshalb
macht man so etwas nicht und genau deshalb kommt aber auch immer wieder dieses Innenministerium sobald irgendwo jemand Kommunikationswege aufgetan hat die Sicht der vollständigen Überwachung und Kontrolle
unterziehen dann sind die bereit alles über Bord zu werfen unglaublich.
Sulz aus
konkret gefährdet das halt jetzt so Dienste du hast schon gesagt WhatsApp aber auch andere populäre messenger wie der Facebook Messenger telegram
iMessage threema Signal es gibt natürlich noch diverse mehr Hocker die Liste ist lang und immer mal wieder haben wir ja auch neue Player die versuchen diesen Markt
noch
irgendwas habhaft zu werden rausgelassen habe ich jetzt über die populären chinesischen Dienste ich glaube das wäre dann wechat vorallem und dann gibt es noch ein Teil was in Japan sehr populär ist also
ich habe jetzt erstmal die aufgezählt dieser Mama hier in unserem in der westlichen Weltordnung primär verwendet werden aber grundsätzlich müsste das sein an für
alle gelten ne und dann halt auch die Frage wie es,
definiert was ist ein Messenger Dienst ist jeder Dienst der in irgendeiner Form das Versenden von messages
erlaubt und verschlüsselt ist fällt der dann auch da drunter also klar wir sind jetzt erstmal am Anfang dieser ganzen politischen Debatte wo man natürlich erstmal dagegenhalten müssen sagen konnte sie noch alle ja also
die Erfahrung zeigt ja immer wieder das zeigen diese Debatten auch
würde sowas eingeführt werden wäre es vor allem erstmal zum Schaden aller aber dann eben wirklich nur zum Vorteil weniger und wie man wie das eben so ist Kriminelle und besonders gut organisierte Kriminelle die.
Bewußt ihre Datenkommunikation auch verschleiern wollen können mühelos dann immer auf einen anderen Dienst ausweichen oder sich vielleicht mal selber noch welche zulegen da ist dann relativ wenig mit.
Gewonnen aber es ist extrem viel damit verloren
das mal ganz abgesehen davon dass natürlich hier auch die ganzen Business Modelle dieser Unternehmen gefährdet werden ja also so ein Unternehmen wie es Riemer
das gesamte Design dieser Software basiert sozusagen auf Verschlüsselung
das da deiner Frau wieder heraus zu operieren ist bedeutet technisch,
alles wegzuschmeißen und damit auch die Grundlage ihrer Existenz wegzuschmeißen weil wer sollte Streamer benutzen wenn wenn da sozusagen die Verschlüsselung nicht mehr greift was der Grund ist warum die Leute da überhaupt dazu gegangen sind
naja also das geht natürlich dann über kurz oder lang eben nicht nur bei Messengers und Messengern sondern wie irgend auch schon erwähnt.
Messaging selber wird ohnehin Teil von nahezu allen werden als wir werden keine büroset mehr erleben die nicht in irgendeiner Form auch solche Kommunikationssysteme hat jedes Game
Multiplayer Netzwerk gehen bietet solche Funktionalitäten da ist dann sozusagen auch kein Ende in Sicht
außerdem möchte man im Innenministerium dann auch drauf drängen dass bei der noch nicht ganz abgeschlossen und technischen Verhandlung über den kommenden 5g Standard,
jedoch möglichst auch auf Beschlüsse verzichtet werden die solche Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung zwanghaft vorschreiben
da muss er sich wahrscheinlich keine großen Sorgen machen weil ich glaube so die Brüder im Geiste ja,
Sauce.
Firmen wir fünf Länder wie Saudi-Arabien oder die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate Iran und andere die gerne wissen möchten was ihre Bürger so tun
wenn du schon dafür sorgen dass man da auf internationaler Ebene bei 5g überhaupt nicht zu irgendeinem Zwang kommen wird.
Ich finde das gerade sehr schön was du noch sagtest und ich glaube da habe ich auch hier in dem Log wo schon öfter mal verglichen.
In den USA gibt es diese sehr komische diesen sehr komischen Satz in einem anderen Kontext wo es um Waffen.
GTA USA senia ihren massiven Waffenbesitz und Waffengebrauch als ein,
Abwehrrecht der Bürgerinnen und Bürger gegen den Staat so zumindest ist es ja in der Verfassung festgehalten,
hast ja so sagen so the right to bear arms also das Recht Waffen Waffen zu haben und zu tragen.
Mit dem Plan einer wohl eine wohlgeformte Militär
Notfall den die den asozialen Start verhindern kann ja das ist die die Recht die die das theoretische Fundament dieses amendments an die Verfassung lange lange Rede kurzer Sinn kann sich viel Gedanken drüber machen ob die Waffen jetzt ernsthaft
wer was bringen denn Trump ist ja immer noch Präsidentin also bisher haben die sich
hat die wohlgeformte beliebt sich noch nicht entschieden er sich zur Wehr zu setzen insofern kann man das in Zweifel ziehen aber was der Satz den die da immer in dem Kontext sagen ist
ist ganzer outlawed only Outlaws have guns also wenn Waffen verboten werden,
dann werden nur die Gesetzlosen sie noch haben und genau das ist im Prinzip in der Verschlüsselung der Fall wenn die jetzt also hingehen und sagen
Verschlüsselung Riesenproblem Riesenproblem darf die Bevölkerung nicht haben ja dann bedeutet das dass nur noch,
kriminelle und nur noch Terroristen über Verschlüsselung verfügen und wir die gesamten Vorteil den,
besondere in der digitalen Welt Verschlüsselung und bietet
als Gesellschaft als Wirtschaft als Individuen komplett über Bord werfen ja und da zeigt sich die völlig skurril überhaupt diese Idee ist etwas zu verbieten was man eben nicht verbieten kann.
Da wird ein Titan schnell in der politischen Diskussion dann das Argument kommen naja aber das ist ja nur auf explizite Herausgabe Wünsche und dann gibt's ja noch einen richterlichen Beschluss das kennen wir ja schon von anderen Maßnahmen der richterlichen Beschluss wird dann am Freitag Nachmittag 16 Uhr
schnell noch mal unterschrieben bevor die Richter in ihr verdientes Wochenende gehen
das hilft halt wenig aber das größere Problem ist dass in dem Moment wo die technische Möglichkeit besteht so etwas zu machen,
natürlich das Missbrauchspotential dann auch in diesen Messenger Unternehmen natürlich stark
na also wenn du so Tank ist eine Möglichkeit gibt an solchen Abgriff vorzunehmen dann weiß er ja auch nicht wer innerhalb dieser Unternehmen unter Umständen
von außen oder aus anderen Quellen korrumpiert wurde und daneben dort mal zugreift und da wieder einen neuen Daten Schwarzmarkt eröffnet also das,
das ist einfach das große Problem und an der Debatte erinnert sich einig in der Grundlage herzlich wenig.
Nicht mich frag ich frage mich noch immer bei diesem Zugriff auf Messenger Dienste durch Behörden stellt sich vor allem noch eine Frage dass diese messenger ja streckenweise.
Durch außen relativ lange Historie vorhalten ja also wenn wenn wir beide wir kennen uns seit schon eine Zeit wenn wir jetzt irgendwann.
In DM in das Visier der Behörden geraten und es erfolgt zum Zeitpunkt einer Anordnung auf den Zugriff unserer Kommunikation.
Dann stellt sich die Frage gilt diese Anordnung ab diesem Moment ja oder können die auch retrograd,
quasi dann schauen und im in Anführungszeichen hochscrollen ne das wird mir hier aus dem Spiegel Artikel,
auch nicht ganz klar hier steht nur künstlich sollen Anbieter dazu gezwungen werden einen ständigen Ansprechpartner in der EU zu benennen und eine Schnittstelle bereitzuhalten auf richterliche Anordnung sollen sie die Kommunikation ihre Kunden mitschneiden und an Behörden schicken,
in lesbarer Form also unverschlüsselt und das ist.
Also einfach vom vom Setup wenn man jetzt so ein so ein Messenger wie threema nehmen würde.
Da ist ja quasi der Key auch die Adresse und wenn du.
Also allein vom Design her kannst du das nicht wirklich machen die sind eben ende-zu-ende verschlüsselt entweder machst du das indem du sagst ok wir heben die Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung auf ja wir sagen also der App auf deinem Telefon jetzt mal bitte nicht mehr verschlüsseln aber,
das würdest Du natürlich merken können oder die sagen okay die App muss.
Auch immer jede Nachrichten noch an einen zweiten Schlüssel verschlüsseln.
Ah das ist also du sendest quasi immer ende-zu-ende verschlüsselt an deinen Kommunikationspartner und den.
Und den den Dienstleister indem in dem Wissen dass der Dienstleister
bei dir im Zweifelsfall auch entschlüsselt was so ein bisschen die gesamte Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung sehr witzlos machen würde weil
die Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung ist ja das primäre Vertrauens versprechen dieser Anbieter dass sie sagen pass auf,
wir können hier viel machen ne aber was wir nicht können ist in deine Daten reinschauen und.
Ich habe keine Lust mehr auf diese diese Gesetzgebungen gegen auch die Nacht wirklich die in dem Fall tatsächlich die Natur der Dinge ja,
wie eben Mathematik und Verschlüsselung funktionieren das haben was machen wir denn.
Das gutefrage also ich meinte nächste Mal muss man da die Debatte wieder aufnehmen weiß gerade nicht ob die Zeiten für die CDU CSU so gut sind neue Vorstöße in digitalien,
zu machen, gleich noch dazu
aber wir wissen ja auch mit welcher Beharrlichkeit in den Sicherheitsbereich vom Innenministerien nicht nur Seehofer genau vorher eigentlich solche Debatten schon immer wieder angestoßen wurden und es ist ja auch nicht so dass Deutschland jetzt hier alleine stehen würde andere Länder haben das halt entweder schon in irgendeiner Form auch
implementiert dass sie Dinge ersticht nicht zugelassen die eben nicht unter ihr Sicherheits Imperium fallen
in Australien gab es ja auch ein ähnlichen Vorstoß und da gabs glaube ich auch ein Beschluss und ich weiß jetzt ehrlich gesagt gerade gar nicht wie das ausgegangen ist dann musst du vielleicht auch noch mal nachrecherchieren
Stopp die Debatte wird zuständig.
Andererseits halte ich das jetzt hier auch in unseren Breiten nicht für.
Ohne weiteres durchsetzbar na aber so wie du das eben gerade beschrieben hast das sind schon so seine A1 geht jetzt gar nicht mal unbedingt nur darum das dann auf einmal alles
nicht mehr verschlüsselt wäre sah es geht halt generell um dieses bitte verschlüsselt doch für uns noch mal mit aber sag dem User nicht dass das jetzt so ist man wenn man
Signal benutzen dann möchte man auf seinem Desktop sein
mit meinem Vater mal mit der großen Tastatur was schreiben dann kann man ja dann quasi seinen eigenen Computer auch nachträglich noch hinzufügen muss das dann natürlich wirst du QR-Code über den Bildschirm noch mal explizit
zulassen dass eben die das eigene Gerät hier quasi seine Verschlüsselungs Kanäle mit dem Rechner,
Teil von daher sind sicherlich technische Lösungen durchaus vorstellbar die aber am Ende
immer bedeuten dass das eigentliche versprechen dass deine Daten sicher sind so nicht mehr gehalten werden.
Na du hast eigentlich ist gerade ein sehr schönes nee das doch das würde wahrscheinlich reichen du bräuchtest eigentlich nur ne ne irgendwie eine Backdoor Funktion in der App dass sie auf.
Auf Befehl ihren Schlüssel freigibt und an den Anbieter sendet ne das wäre so die die am.
Chen nicht in schlüsselfreies oder noch andere sozusagen für andere noch mit verschlüsseln.
Ja aber dann hätte dann hättest du das könntest du ja sehen da steht ja im im also in der Nachricht kannst du ja erkennen.
An wie viele andere Schlüsse die mit verschlüsselt ist das heißt da würde sich die App auch jedesmal wieder verraten wenn jemand in traffic schauen würde,
was nicht so ohne weiteres möglich ist aber wenn du einfach sagst ok die app schießt auf Befehl in einem unbeobachteten Moment nachts mal ganz kurz in Kiel,
da und da hin zur zur Entschlüsselung aller Nachrichten,
dann würdest du es nicht immer sehen können aber ich höre jetzt auf über Designs und Architektur hier zu spekulieren weil das sind nachher nur wieder Tipps wie man es am besten machen würdet.
Halt dich jetzt den den Mund verhindern müssen wir es auf jeden Fall das ist so ein klassischer Fall von wir werden.
Von unserer Rentner Regierung daran gehindert die Vorzüge des digitalen zu nutzen während wir
wirklich genötigt werden auch wirklich jeden einzelnen Nachteil des digitalen und jeder einzelne Herausforderung des digitalen in,
in vollem Ungemach mit mit allen negativen Konsequenzen möglichst knallharte auszubauen.
Die beste Methode Bösewichten hinter hinters Licht zu führen also die sozusagen ihn auf die Schliche zu kommen ist sowieso eine ganz andere.
Man nimmt einfach ein paar Schauspieler und ruf da einfach mal an und fragt ob sie auch nicht einfach mal alles erzählen.
Hey we going to Ibiza.
Und ein paar versteckte Kamera.
Und auf Video.
Also man nehme eine Villa auf Ibiza baut überall Überwachungskameras und Mikrofone verdeckt ein,
und dann sitzen wir noch ein paar hübsche Frauen auf Sofa und schon fangen wir alle an zu erzählen.
DAK also werden wir sprechen an das Thema Sprache Video und da das jetzt glaube ich schon 10 Tage oder was her ist dass dieses Video,
von der Süddeutschen Zeitung und der Spiegel veröffentlicht wurde.
Begnügen wir uns mit einer kurzen Zusammenfassung was ist passiert der Herr Hans Christian Strache und seine.
Deine rechte Hand und ich glaube der Partei Obmann war sein ist der Begriff.
Sonst Herr Ferienorten.
Fraktionschef Gudenus finden sich in auf Ibiza in einer schönen Airbnb Villa wieder die mit von oben bis unten voll ist mit Kameras und treffen sich dort.
Mit einer russischen Oligarchen oder.
Angeblichen.
Einer angeblichen russischen Oligarchen die.
Re verschiedene Interessen bekundet hat unter anderem sie wolle doch ganz gerne die Kronen Zeitung kaufen oder große Anteil an der Kronenzeitung
sie würde gerne Staatsaufträge in Österreich bekommen gegen
illegale Parteispenden und gegen diese Möglichkeit die Kronen Zeitung zu übernehmen und so der FPÖ.
Verschiedene Vorteile in der Wahl zu verschaffen.
Und Gudenus und insbesondere Strache sitzen da sieben Stunden dauert diese Aufnahme von der allerdings nur.
Kleinere Ausschnitte veröffentlicht wurden auf dem Sofa und erklären seelenruhig wie ihr illegaler Parteispenden Apparat funktioniert,
ja wie also Spenden an einen Verein gehen welcher dann die Partei unterstützt umso die Meldepflichten
an den Bundesrechnungshof zu umgehen sie benennen mehrere illegale.
Illegale Spender die sie angeblich haben diese Spender bestreiten dass zwar aber das hätte ich an deren Stelle auch getan.
Und ansonsten trinken Sie noch eine ganze Menge Red Bull und unterhalten sich darüber wie scharf doch diese.
Russische Oligarchen sei.
Also wer die bei dieses kurzen Ausschnitt aus dem langen Aufzeichnungen noch nicht gesehen hat schaut euch das auf jeden Fall an das ist großes Kino also lächerlicher kann man sich eigentlich auch gar nicht,
präsentieren also selbst für jemanden der sozusagen der so korrupt ist war das schon sowas von unprofessionell das macht einen echt Fassung.
Noch nicht mal in der Korruption professionell ja wo ist denn dein Anstand wo ist dein Anspruch an dich selber.
Ja das Ganoven ihre einfach vollkommen verprasst.
Also es ist nnn Mitleid erregendes Bild.
Und es war ein Erdbeben in Österreich ein politisches Erdbeben des begann kurz nach der Veröffentlichung dieses Videos das war glaube ich an einem Freitag Nachmittag wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche.
Kurz darauf der Rücktritt Straches der aber schon und das war da ist mir auch mal wieder das,
Blut in den Adern gefroren von einer fürchterlichen Verschwörung und kriminellen redet die ihn
mit Geheimdienst mit Hoden und Hilfe außer im ausländischer Geheimdienste in diese Situation gebracht haben und ihn betrunken gemacht hätten um um ihn zu zerstören,
und was nicht alles also völliger Irrsinn.
Der einzige der an der ganzen Sache keine Schuld trägt das ist klar ist Hans Christian Strache ne wir müssen uns darüber im Klaren sein Hans Christian Strache ist hier das Opfer.
Die ist reichischen Nation ist das Opfer und das ganze war eine Aktion ausländische Geheimdienste zur Zerstörung seiner Ehe wir sehen.
Die Sonne.
Ist die einzige die noch zu Hans Christian Strache gehalten hat und sich weiterhin einzig und allein um ihn dreht aber sonst haben ihn hier alle verraten ist eine fürchterliche Verschwörung und er hat dann auch gesagt außerdem.
Sei ja das Anfertigen dieser Videoaufnahmen,
illegal gewesen ganz im Gegenteil die ist ein Apfel und ein Ei an irgendeine dahergelaufene russische Oligarchen zu verscherbeln das war völlig okay na also dann,
wird ja auch quasi das ist ja seine Privatsphäre.
Jana darf also keiner dass das geht so natürlich nicht weiterhin.
Was ich sehr mit sehr viel mit der Spannung verfolgt habe weil dieses Ausbleiben einer ursprünglich an den Tag für 12 Uhr angekündigten Pressekonferenz des.
Des Bundeskanzlers Österreich nämlich Sebastian Kurz der dann erst auf 12 Uhr dann auf 14 Uhr dann auf 16 Uhr und am Ende glaube ich um 19:45 Uhr seine Pressekonferenz zu dem Thema gehalten hat und in der Zwischenzeit.
Und da habe ich wirklich gedacht was für ein politisches.
Was für eine politmagazine der hat natürlich den den Braten gerochen und festgestellt dass er jetzt hier gerade
die Gunst der Stunde nutzen kann mit einer kurzen
mit einem kurzen Nachmittag der langen Messer die komplette FPÖ Spitze aus seiner Regierung da Köpfen kann und wenn er jetzt maximalen Abstand zwischen sich und dieser FPÖ bringt.
Mit Glück sehr viele Prozentpunkte gewinnen kann in der nächsten Wahl um unter Umständen eben alleine,
zu regieren oder mit einem anderen schwächeren Koalitionspartner von mir aus auch mit dem gleichen Konditionen Partner der hat ja dann quasi.
Jetzt den Rücktritt also hat gesagt er will Neuwahlen er hat den Rücktritt alle FPÖ Minister.
Dann entgegengenommen und will nun eine Expertenregierung stattdessen haben was er auch mal was neues werden da so.
Von Experten regiert zu werden die FDP Stadt der FPÖ das ist auch keine schlechte Idee bedeutet in dem Fall dass die Ministerposten eben mit.
Ja mit.
Zumindest Terium besetzt wer.
Leuten aus dem Ministerium kommissarisch besetzt werden vielleicht keine so blöde Idee vielleicht aber auch eine blöde Idee je nachdem wen die da so auf den Sekretärs posten und sonst war sitzen hatten.
Wenn ich das richtig erinnere blickt er jetzt am kommenden Montag noch auf ein Misstrauensvotum.
Und dann schauen wir mal was daraus wird die das nächste Thema was dann aber aufkam ist.
Wer sind die Hintermänner,
was ist da los wär wer hat hier welcher ausländische Geheimdienste war dass es gab dann die die eine Reihe an an völlig absurden Theorien die ich auch
relativ amüsant immer fand also in Wien dann sollte es der Böhmermann sein denn dann sollte es das Zentrum für politische Schönheit sein dann ne.
Warum hat Sissi uns das nicht gesagt.
Haley.
Da haben sie doch haben sie doch zu allem befragt.
Wenn ihr es war dann gibt uns jetzt kein Zeichen also völlig völlig völlig bescheuert und an.
Nun ist es ja so so so bescheuert sich dieser gut enus und der Strafe darauf führen unsere inkompetent und,
blöd sie sich da verhalten so ist es ja doch klar dass dass das jetzt nicht
ohne weiteres sie ohne vertraute zu Rate zu ziehen plötzlich zur für Verschwörung gegen
gegen den Staat in sie regieren wollen nach Ibiza fliegen und sich überlegen wie sie den
an irgendjemanden verscheuern können na das ist ja jetzt irgendwie nicht so als finde jeden Abend in der Kneipe sitzen warten dass das die nächstbeste Russin reinkommt und ihr sagen kommen wir wir machen hier ein,
konkreten Plot so und wir haben folgende folgende Vereine schon für dich bereit und es war denke ich von vornherein,
Mitsorge damit zu rechnen dass die Menschen die das in die Wege geleitet haben.
Ja in irgendeiner Form ausfindig gemacht werden und die Presse dann ihr übriges tut und es Strache sagte ja auch schon an diesem Tag dass er Hinweise habe auf.
Die Person die ihm das angetan haben und deren Hintermänner und meine Vermutung bestätigte sich dann auch dass er natürlich weiß.
Wie er da auf einmal auf Ibiza gelandet ist und wer die entsprechenden Kontakte hergestellt hat und wer für wen,
gebürgt hat und jetzt sind wir quasi habe ich sogar den Eindruck am Anfang der zweiten Welle dieser Auseinandersetzung nämlich der wo sich nun das,
die moralische Bewertung.
Auf jene ergießt die hier dem Land Österreich den großen großen Dienst erwiesen haben,
einen eindeutig korrupten Politiker der konkrete Pläne geschmiedet hat ja zum Nachteil.
Dieses Staates ja Staatsaufträge Schanze ich dir zu ich mache ein österreichisches Unternehmen platt ins ihr den die Staatsaufträge und gebe die stattdessen hier dir liebe,
russische Frau auf meinem Airbnb Sofa.
Was da passiert ist ist ein ein sehr sehr großer Dienst an der,
Republik Österreich und wer sich da über irgendwelche.
Über irgendwelchen Quatsch aufregt wie dass das mit einer versteckten Kamera stattgefunden hätte da habe ich den Eindruck dass die Leute die nicht verstehen was hier gerade passiert ist,
denn ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass sich das irgendjemand auf die E.
Eine solche Situation herbeizuführen ohne nicht auch schon vorher einen Anhaltspunkt dafür zu haben dass das funktioniert ja.
Bei jedem anderen Politiker würdest Du erwarten.
Wenn du denn eine solche Situation stellst dass er von sich aus sofort sagt Böhmermann Böhmermann wo bist du komm raus,
und das Koks vom Tisch schiebt und die Red Bull nicht auf trinkt sondern hier hast du halt irgendwie Leute die sehr konkret in dieser Angelegenheit sind und.
Es kristallisiert sich ja auch heraus dass das nicht das erste Treffen war und das ist auch nicht das einzige Treffen war sondern dass der Strache immer wieder nachgefragt hat was ist mit dieser mit dieser Person insofern würde ich hier,
sehr vorsichtig mal davon ausgehen dass diejenigen die diese Situation herbeigeführt haben lange genug wussten.
Welches Spiel er spielt und welches Spiel er ja dann auch vor diesen versteckten Kameras eben offenbart,
und deswegen sehe ich das hier eindeutig im im Rahmen des Whistleblowing ist und ich muss echt sagen diese Person brauchen jetzt den.
Uneingeschränkten Schutz und die uneingeschränkte Anerkennung denn jetzt wo deren,
ja je nachdem welches Zeitung du auf schlägst Vornamen Bilder verpixelt und unverpixelt und so weiter kursieren.
Ja
Haben die ja und dieses Risiko das mussten die einkalkulieren ja die haben ihre Existenz geopfert die haben alles was Sie bis dahin in ihrem Leben erreicht haben.
Aufgegeben mit dieser Sache und dafür brauchen die,
einfach nur Schutz und Anerkennung und jede Verurteilung von irgendwelchen dahergelaufenen Moralaposteln,
die jetzt irgendwie die die wahrscheinlich auch noch gesagt hätten ja also
es tut mir leid der der Stauffenberg mit dem Attentat des das ist so nicht in Ordnung ne wir müssen den Hitler mit demokratischen schlagen und warten bis wir das nächste Mal eine freie Wahl haben die haben glaube ich dir einfach die die Ernsthaftigkeit der Auseinandersetzung hier
immer noch nicht ganz Wagener.
Du sagtest ja gerade es zeichnet sich ab dass sie da auch später noch Kontakt hatten was man vielleicht noch erwähnen sollte ist die Sache mit der Pressemitteilung also
die falschen oli garchen haben ja dann sozusagen gefordert für den Vorschlag den er gemacht hat mit der Strabag und herum Verteilung der Staatsaufträge
dass sie sozusagen um um sozusagen ihre Bereitschaft das auch wirklich
zu leisten zu dokumentieren eine Pressemitteilung rauszugeben in der halt verklausuliert auch die Strabag erwähnt wird sozusagen so eine Art fingerprinting das dass sie zu dieser Aussage auch immer noch stehen und die gab es ja dann auch nachweislich
also die sind auf jeden Fall hochgradig korrupt und sind extrem,
ja unterwegs neue Verschwörungstheorien aufkommen zu lassen der guzinos sprach er schon vonovia KO-Tropfen im Spiel und da kommt ja dann sicherlich noch mehr und sowas
soll nach ko tropfen Salat für mich ehrlich gesagt nicht aus aber wir holen halt irgendwie alles aus dem Schrank was sie noch irgendwie einfällt
und aber auch der Herr kurz hier der Kinder Kanzler
ist ja auch sofort in deiner ersten Antwort Verschwörungstheorien nicht.
Schuldig geblieben und Finger dann gleich also nimmt Shopping zu machen mit diesem Herrn Silberstein er ist sozusagen die schalt Figur des vorhergegangenen großen Politskandal stin
Silberstein Skandal wo halt die ÖVP sich wiederum hat jetzt schon die SPÖ sich wiederum
er hat nachweisen lassen müssen dass sie damit unlauteren Propaganda Methoden gegen die ÖVP vorgegangen sind also die haben alle Dreck am Stecken
du dich immer da auch irgendwie schießen Österreich bezogen immer die richtigen es ist wirklich unfassbar da und jetzt,
müssen mal schauen was dabei rauskommt dass ich würd sagen dieses Misstrauensvotum hat durchaus Chancen zum Erfolg.
Sonst müsste ja die FPÖ für den Kanzler stimmen was ich mir irgendwie so recht nicht vorstellen kann wie sie das dann
Zusage nach innen abbilden wollen die Opposition wird auf jeden Fall dagegen stimmen das bedeutet dass kurzzeitjob auch etwas kurzfristiger loswerden dürfte im September soll dann gewählt werden.
Vermutlich so gegen zweite dritte Woche wenn ich das richtig sehe von der Terminlage her steht glaube ich noch nicht ganz fest.
Ja was Mama ist raus also das ist auf jeden Fall eine interessante Wendung vor allem so kurz vor der Europawahl ich bin sehr gespannt welche Auswirkungen das hat in Österreich oder vielleicht auch darüber hinaus.
Matthias nicht so den Eindruck dass alle sofort verstanden haben woher der Wind weht so gibt immer noch genug Leute die trotzdem FPÖ wählen warum auch immer Sie das für angemessen halten so oder so aber Österreich noch im
bisschen noch mal von der Klippe von der sagt man wovon ist man doch eher weg gesprungen wenn man sich dran unterklippe will.
Von der Klippe gesprungen.
Ja so dann dann.
Achso andere Richtung.
Ja es wird gerade die Assoziation von der Klinge.
Von der Klinge von der Klinge gesprungen.
War jetzt bitte die ein oder andere angedrohte Gesetzesverschärfung vielleicht noch mal ausbleiben.
Ja das wäre das wäre sehr schön dann hätten wir da hätten wir da vielleicht eine kurze Verschnaufpause für seine Thomas Lohninger epicenter works und so haben jetzt wenigstens mal diese
diese Ausweispflicht im Internet könnte.
Hier jetzt wenn man Glück hat pausieren weil eben auch der gute Herr kickel nicht mehr,
Innenminister der Republik Österreich ist könnte es sich hier Abzeichnen dass es eine Verschnaufpause gibt.
Diesel aus ministeria diese aus dem Müll Außenministerin die vor Putin den GTX gemacht hat die ist aber immer noch am Abend ne weil die ja offiziell ich FPÖ Mitglied war und noch nicht gehen möchte.
Da bin ich leider nicht hundertprozentig Einbildung muss ich sagen.
Ja das war mein letzter Stand.
Also ich finde auf jeden Fall gespannt die nächsten Wochen werden wir dann übergossen werden mit allerlei Verschwörungstheorien um,
diejenigen die diese Situation herbeigeführt haben und die Bedingungen unter denen die Veröffentlichung Stadt
das ist relativ klar dass hier jetzt eine schwere Nebel von
von Verschwörungstheorien drauf gegossen werden muss wird irgendwie versucht werden diese Menschen zu kriminalisieren denn also lese ich,
darauf steht bis zu ein Jahr Haft
dass sie den heimlich gefilmt haben diese Kriminellen Schweine ja dass er unmöglich dass der davor hatte denke ich ist ja relativ klar
dass die Person die diese Situation herbeigeführt hat,
erstens sehr klar wusste was er da tat und auch wussten dass das Erfolg haben wird und auch wussten das was sie hier tun,
ja und dass sie hier an einen,
bei Antidemokraten bekämpfen und da sehe ich wirklich habe ich persönlich nur sehr wenig Verständnis für jene die jetzt hier,
versuchen irgendwelche wirklich sehr.
An den Haaren herbeigezogen and Argumente herbeizuführen warum das jetzt irgendwie,
falsch war und doch richtig und nicht müde werden zu betonen dass man aber Person nicht heimlich filmen darf ja darf man nicht völlig klar hier hat eine ein kleiner,
Gesetzesverstoß stattgefunden um mehr oder weniger die,
die Regierungsbeteiligung eines durch und durch korrupten Kriminellen zu verhindern und wenn man sich überlegt dass die FPÖ
spätestens nach der Wahl das Innenministerium kontrolliert hat ist wohl auch klar dass jene die das in die Wege geleitet haben eben auch mit der Polizei dürfen sie es gewollt hätten in diesem Land nicht hätten konkurrieren können mehr.
Darf man ja nicht vergessen wenn du die wenn du die die korrupten erstmal in dem in der Politik hast im Innenministerium ja dann wird es schwierig mit rechtlichen Mitteln.
Gegen sie vorzugehen.
Sulz in Österreich aus in Deutschland die habe über das Fusion-Festival in der letzten Folge lange gesprochen.
Und auch da hat sich einiges getan seit unserer letzten Sendung die,
Zusammenfassung der letzten des Standes der letzten Woche ist ja gewesen seit 22 Jahren gibt es dieses Festival seit 22 Jahren gab es Dani größere,
Probleme was die Sicherheit der Beteiligten angeht und,
nun meldete sich die Polizei eben mit dem Anspruch auf dem Gelände eine Polizeiwache einzurichten.
Und dem Anspruch das Gelände anlasslos mit Polizeistreifen zu durchkämmen und,
als Hebel für ihren Anspruch wurde immer angeführt Mängel am Sicherheitskonzept
diese Menge waren immer wieder neue und so
ging dieses Spiel ja auch schon seit November letzten Jahres immer hin und her bist ein Visa für die hat das geht aber nicht und das geht aber nicht und die Polizei mehr oder minder immer hat durchblicken lassen Servicer
also solange wir da nicht eine Wache auf dem Gelände haben können wir uns irgendwie einfach nicht vorstellen eurem Sicherheitskonzept zuzustimmen können wir uns einfach gar nicht vorstellen.
Nun war es so dass der Kulturkosmos erneut.
Zum ich weiß noch nicht mal mehr wievielten Mal das Sicherheitskonzept überarbeitet hat und der.
Dem Amt vorgelegt hat ich hatte erklärt die Genehmigung erfolgt durch das Ordnungsamt,
in Rücksprache mit allen relevanten zuständigen Behörden was dann irgendwie über Bauamt und Polizei und sonstiges geht und da spielt daneben das Sicherheitskonzept und die äußeren der Polizei
eine Rolle der Kulturkosmos hat.
Noch mal an diesem Sicherheitskonzept gearbeitet es gab der ja verschiedene Forderungen die auch nachvollziehbar waren und die,
der Kulturkosmos ist verständlich umgesetzt hat denn hier geht es ja nicht darum dass der Kulturkosmos das Ziel hätte diese Veranstaltung in die möglichst ohne Sicherheitsmaßnahmen durchzuführen sondern es geht darum dass der Kulturkosmos die natürlich,
die Sicherheit der Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmer an oberste Stelle setzen und nur gerne auch dafür sorgen würde dass das so bleibt.
Amt das wurde also eingereicht und man wartete jetzt auf die Entscheidung von Seiten,
des Amtes bezüglich der Genehmigung
der Veranstaltung in diesem neuen Sicherheitskonzept stand aber immer noch nicht wie von der Polizei gefordert drin dass sie auf der dass sie in die anlasslos auf dem Gelände residieren und im Schichtbetrieb Streife gehen,
dürfen sondern der stand drin auf dem Flugplatzgelände außerhalb.
Jazzfestival Bereiches.
Genehmigen wir oder sorgen wir dafür dass die Polizei sich dort eine Niederlage eine temporäre Mobile Wache einrichten kann jetzt kommen die Leute manchmal durcheinander mit Flugplatzgelände und Festivalgelände.
Der Ahnen Kulturkosmos angrenzende Flugplatz wird für die Dauer des Festivals mit,
angemietet und dann wird quasi einen gibt es ja quasi den Bereich der jetzt zum Festival gehört quasi wo ein Eingang ist wo ein Zaun ist und wo eine Bändchen Kontrolle ist.
Das ist der Festival breit der ist natürlich etwas kleiner als der als das gesamte Gelände Flugplatz und Kulturkosmos und auf dem Flugplatz also in unmittelbarer Nähe der Veranstaltung nicht jedoch auf dem.
Veranstaltungsgelände soll eine wurde eine Mobile Wache vorgeschlagen und anlassbezogen.
Der Zugang.
Der Polizei zum Veranstaltungsgelände gewährt mit der weiteren Hinweis wenn sich dieser Anlass erledigt hat erfolgt der unmittelbare Rückzug,
ja und wir wollen mal gucken ist eben kein an das war der Stand den.
Der Kulturkosmos dort abgegeben hat und dann passierte am Freitag war das am Freitag nee am Montag.
Am Montag dieser Woche passierte dann eine Veröffentlichung von ZEIT-Online die also wirklich auch.
Wieder mal etwas warum ihr das Blut in den Adern gefror und zwar veröffentlichte Zeit online einen Artikel.
In dem zitiert wurde aus dem Einsatzkonzept der Polizei für.
Das Fusion-Festival das ist ein relativ langes Dokument wo eben drin aus GE.
Dargestellt wird wie die Polizei beabsichtigt.
Was sie für Kräfte braucht welche Aktionen da durchgeführt werden für welche Eventualitäten was vorgehalten wird und da stand dann
so schöne Sachen drin wir ja irgendwie um die 1000 Polizisten und Polizisten was wir ja schon wussten dass sie mit so vielen Leuten
plane die im Dreischichtbetrieb
24-Stunden auf diesem Gelände neben Streife gehen verdeckt und uniformiert.
Desweiteren war Räumpanzer und Wasserwerfer vorgesehen und,
die der Einsatz der Social Media Abteilung um bei Auseinandersetzungen die Deutungshoheit zu gewinnen wo dann auch so würde dir denkst du alter jetzt jetzt geht's aber echt.
Und ja also ein einen völlig völlig wahnsinniges,
Konzept was hier also,
sich offenbar liest sie so eine Vorbereitung auf einen Bürgerkrieg entsprechend hat sich der Kulturkosmos dann auch nach dem Zeit online uns mit diesen
Inhalten
konfrontiert hat geäußert ja es ist mein hast ein friedliches folkshilfe seit bald einem Vierteljahrhundert und dann gibt's irgendeine Einsatzkonzept mit mit mit Wasserwerfern und Räumpanzer ne
das stimmt wirklich nur der wird dir echt der wird ja sowieso schon mal Angst und Bange.
Das geht aber noch weiter diese Artikel das war ja erstmal nur so wie man so schön sagt die Spitze des Eisbergs denn.
Offenbar gibt es an der Oder gab es wurde eingereicht an der Polizei Fachhochschule Güstrow.
Eine Bachelorarbeit und diese Bachelorarbeit hat zum hat irgendwie die Betrachtung der des Open Air Festivals Fusion zum Inhalt mit Hinblick auf.
Einsatzszenarien durch Behörden oder so ja also irgendwie eine eine Bachelorarbeit die an einer polizeifachhochschule geschrieben wurde.
Und quasi dort ein mehr oder weniger quasi die seine adressrisiko Evaluation der des Festivals vornimmt und.
Diesel.
Diese Bachelorarbeit wieder also ich meine eine polizeifachhochschule ist irgendwie so eine Schule ganze Zeit was weiß ich was man da machen dann wird man dann Kommissarin oder Kommissar oder sowas ne und der Betreuer dieser Bachelorarbeit.
Heißt.
Ulf Theodor Claassen ist also Polizei.
Dozent an dieser Polizei Fachhochschule Güstrow und der ne relativ interessante Vorgeschichte erstens war er zusammen mit dem Nils Hoffmann Ritterbusch.
In beim G8 Gipfel im Heil in Heiligendamm und Rostock haben die beiden eng zusammengearbeitet.
Der Polizeipräsident.
Der jetzige Polizeipräsident von Neubrandenburg von dem aus diese gesamte Nummer ausgeht.
Also der der Hoffmann Ritterbusch ist der Polizeipräsident von Neubrandenburg der dieses gesamte Theater mit dem Sicherheitskonzept reicht nicht aus wir wollen dort 1000 Polizeikräfte haben und so von dem geht das auf,
und das ist ein alter Kollege von diesem polizeifachhochschule Dozenten Ulf Theodor Claassen.
Der rein zufällig über die Fusion diese Abhandlung geschrieben hat.
Der rein zufällig über die Fusion die Bachelorarbeit betreut hat in der eine genaue Prüfung,
hinsichtlich Polizeieinsatz Szenarien stattfindet.
Und im Rahmen dieser Bachelorarbeit der Autor dieser Bachelorarbeit.
Brauchte ja irgendwie Material und dieses Material hat er bekommen.
Unter anderem von dem Polizeipräsidium Neubrandenburg so wie ich das hier verstehe und dazu gehörte das Sicherheitskonzept der Veranstalter des Fusion-Festival in dem eine Reihe an sensiblen Informationen sind.
Relativ viele Telefonnummern Telefonnummern stehen da drin
Personen ne verantwortlicher Strategien für den Umgang mit Angriffen und Großereignissen ein Sicherheitskonzept ist grundsätzlich eher nicht für die Öffentlichkeit bestimmt und weißt du warum man sowas nicht für die Öffentlichkeit bestimmt weil
man ja z.b. Sorge hat das irgendwelche rechten Gewalttäter unter kenntniss des Sicherheitskonzeptes
unter Umständen einen Angriff auf die Veranstaltung durchführen,
und jetzt stellt sich raus dieser gute Ulf Theodor Claassen wenn er früher irgendwie 2007 noch mit der Einsatzplanung
zum G8 Gipfel betraut war dann fragt man sich was macht der arme Mann denn jetzt an irgendeiner polizeifachhochschule am Arsch der Heide ja stellt sich raus dahin wurde er strafversetzt
nachdem er als Gewalttäter rechtskräftig verurteilt wurde weil er.
An seinem wahlstand für die AFD deren Kandidat er war.
Menschen mit Pfefferspray angegriffen hat die mit Konfetti vor seinem wahlstand ihr wieder Monster.
Nono.
Also dieser Klassen ist ein rechtskräftig verurteilter Gewalttäter mit einem AFD background und in dessen Händen.
Befindet sich also ich jetzt in dessen vertrauenswürdigen Händen befindet sich jetzt eine alte Version des Fusion Sicherheitskonzeptes unter Benennung aller persönlichen Ansprechpartner,
mit persönlichen Daten und Handynummern und so weiter ungesperrt.
Weiß man woher woher das hatte.
Wenn ich das richtig verstehe es gibt ja nur eine Instanz wo der did her haben kann bzw zwei wenn man es genau nimmt das wäre dieses Amt röbel-müritz oder eben die Polizei.
Dass der Polizeipräsidium dessen Präsident sein alter Kumpel ist.
Mit Emma zusammen schön irgendwie.
Schlafen kann aber natürlich muss ich jetzt auch für die Vollständigkeit sagen der Klasen kann natürlich,
sagen ich habe dir Sicherheitskonzept zum ersten Mal gesehen als bei mir diese Bachelorarbeit eingereicht wurde nein das ist im Zweifelsfall nicht wahr aber das ist ja nachvollziehbare weg
zunächst einmal hat dieser der Autor dieser Bachelorarbeit offenbar das irgendwo angefragt nichts genaues weiß man nicht kenn ja auch die gesamten Dokumente nicht wir wohnen ja nur von Zeit online hier,
mit den paar Tagen und Ausschnitten konfrontiert.
Klingt aufjedenfall so als ob sie demnächst vor die Kamera gehen sein dass er irgendwo ja KO-Tropfen gegeben und sie wissen überhaupt.
Du fragst Dich erst ab da siehst du.
Dass ich auf der Zunge zergehen lassen sensibel Informationen zur Sicherheitsvorkehrung und Sicherheitspersonal persönliche Daten Telefonnummern wurden an rechtsextrem Gewalttäter weitergegeben.
Der noch dazu ein alter buddy ist von der Polizeipräsident in Neubrandenburg das stinkt natürlich bis zum Himmel.
Reitverein man kann ja auch sagen wenn hier irgendetwas das Sicherheitskonzept der Fuzion bedroht in diesem Fall dann ist es ja offensichtlich die Polizei an der Stelle.
Völliger.
Also wenn die noch nicht mal mit solchen sensitiven Materialien ordentlich umgehen können das ist ja wirklich krass.
Völliger Irrsinn die Veröffentlichung hat natürlich also die Veröffentlichung ZEIT-Online hat natürlich sofort irgendwie.
Jack Russel Kreise gezogen ist nicht hinein wirklich einen ein politisches Erdbeben da durch die Region gegangen die Polizei ruderte sofort mit großem paddeln zurück und meine ja ja also hier bitte.
Mit dem neuen Sicherheitskonzept brauchen wir den Räumpanzer und den Wasserwerfer nicht und außerdem haben wir den Wasserwerfer ja nur gehabt dass wir die Leute Briefen können wenn es zu heiß wird.
Na das haben sie sich gesagt.
Klar ich also gesagt die Anette auf Twitter drehen die völlig durch.
Und du kennst ja du kennst das ja von der nation of Gondwana wenn es da zu heiß ist ne da freut man sich wenn die Feuerwehr mal ein bisschen Wasser aus dem Teich in den Himmel Streit damit man einen kühlen
Nebel aus Flüssigkeit erhält ja das ist ja auch völlig in Ordnung ich bin mir nicht sicher ob irgendjemand das genauso amüsant findet wenn ein Polizei Wasserwerfer 2000 kommt,
völlig absurd.
Aber ich meine wir haben ja hier oft darüber gesprochen dass eben Sorge besteht insbesondere mit diesen ganzen AFD.
Leuten in der Polizei in den in der Innenpolitik dass dieser Apparat eben.
Tatsächlich inzwischen als unterwandert bezeichnet werden kann und da sehen wir wirklich denke einerseits mit dem Sprache Video wunderbare Beispiele und auch mit diesem wirklich krassen Vorgängen.
In Mecklenburg-Vorpommern ich denke hier ist es nicht zu viel verlangt wenn man sagt also wenn wir selbst der Polizei.
Diese hier als als sicherer unserer Sicherheit profilieren möchte wenn wir selbst eher nicht mehr vertrauen können dann läuft wirklich etwas massiv schief.
Und der Chaos Computer Club ist dann auch noch mit einer Pressemitteilung an den Start gegangen und hat die.
Natürlich politische Konsequenzen personelle Konsequenzen gefordert der Innenminister,
Mecklenburg-Vorpommerns war dann dass das war glaube ich am Freitag war einer Debatte im Landtag Mecklenburg-Vorpommern wo er wild am Rudern war und.
Schließlich aber dann ganz klar sagte.
Es wird dadurch dass es ja jetzt einen anlassbezogenen Zugang zum Gelände gibt.
Sehr er bitte.
Gab ja den es schon immer gab aber jetzt mit dem neuen Sicherheitskonzept sehe er keinen Anlass mehr,
auf dem Gelände durchzuführen und das bedeutet dass hier.
Diese wie ich ehrlich gesagt jetzt kann ich es ja sagen ursprünglich sehr,
diese Situation die ich sehr aussichtslos anfangs eingeschätzt habe sich nun erstens doch,
zum guten klärt und zweitens
und auch zum handfesten polizeiskandal ausweiten wo du wirklich nicht mehr weißt wo oben und unten ist ich gehe nicht davon aus dass dieses Thema jetzt damit
erledigt ist ich bin gespannt ob die Polizei nun auch tatsächlich.
Quasi zu dem Wort des Innenministers steht und sagt okay wir werden hier uns wir werden diese Sicherheitskonzept genehmigen zunächst einmal sind wieder erneute neue Auflagen formuliert worden.
Noch mal welche zusätzlich.
Ja gibt wieder neue Auflagen die umzusetzen sind.
Genaue Anzahl kenne ich nicht aber die ist nicht gering signifikant sind davon glaube ich ungefähr zwei wo,
jetzt gerade daran gearbeitet wird auch die selbstverständlich umzusetzen auch wenn sie jetzt wirklich langsam in einem Bereich sind der nicht mehr so einfach,
nachvollziehbar ist aber denke man kann hier insgesamt sagen wir haben es geschafft von einer Maximalforderung der Polizei die sich hier,
offensichtlich für eine für ein Bürgerkriegs ähnlichen Zustand gerüstet hat für den es überhaupt keinen Anlass gab.
Auf eine Situation gekommen sind und wo sich nichts ändert,
an dem Status Quo außer dass die Polizei nun außerhalb des Geländes eine Mobile Wache,
errichten kann umso im Bedarfsfall anlassbezogen schneller zum Schutz der Veranstaltung und der Gäste,
verfügbar sein kann was grundsätzlich ja nichts verkehrtes ist also.
Tina Sohn Container.
Ich weiß nicht wie eine Bombe Mobile Wache aussieht ich hoffe ein kleiner Wohnwagen reicht doch oder.
Neu versichern wollte noch mit tausend Leuten kommen dann müssen wir auch wo rein kriegen.
Wir können natürlich,
wir werden natürlich jetzt beobachten ob den Worten des Innenministers auch Taten folgen dann die Unterkünfte müssten ja dann jetzt für die 1000 Polizisten müssten ja dann jetzt.
Storniert sein.
Am das werden wir sehen ob das tatsächlich so ist es gibt natürlich noch einen anderen Weg den ich jetzt hier.
Persönlich fürchte ich mein ich bin ich betrachte einfach immer jedes Risiko und hier wird es natürlich jetzt durchaus das Risiko dass die Polizei nach dieser.
Wirklich nachhaltigen Blamage die sie dann auch noch direkt in den eigenen Skandal im eigenen Haus geritten hat.
Durchaus ein Interesse hat am Ende noch als Letzter zu lachen insofern bin ich natürlich durchaus von der Sorge getrieben.
Das nun auch von außerhalb des Geländes irgendeine Form der Eskalation.
Herbeigeführt wird ja und das ist natürlich für so eine für eine Polizei die es darauf anlegt,
immer sehr einfach hinzukriegen na also wenn du als Polizei sagt ich möchte jetzt aber hier.
Dazu beitragen dass hier eine Situation entsteht die mich in die Situation versetzt.
Maßnahmen einleiten zu dürfen oder sogar zu müssen dann kannst du das natürlich tun du kannst einfach die du kannst dich da hinsetzen und sagen okay wir warten hier bis irgendwas kommt oder du kannst halt mal.
Die ein oder andere unverfängliche Situation herbeiführen bis dir mal jemand krumm kommt,
da kannst du mal sagen okay zeig doch mal deine aus weißt du auch was tust du nicht ok dann müssen wir dich jetzt leider in Gewahrsam nehmen weil du,
und dich erkennungsdienstlich behandeln weil wir müssen ja wissen wer du bist und wie das so läuft ne also ich bin da immer noch von Sorge getragen dass die dass ihre Bürgerkrieg Szenarien da doch noch in irgendeiner Form,
herbeiführen.
Und da kann man natürlich nur hoffen dass alle Besucherinnen und Besucher der Veranstaltung sich da möglichst wie auch sonst von niemandem provozieren lassen der da irgendwie.
Komisches im Schädel.
Naja also kann natürlich auch sein dass Zeitpunkt des physischen Staats Polizeipräsident vielleicht gar nicht Polizeipräsident ist je nachdem was alles noch ausgegraben wird da scheint ja doch noch dass die eine oder andere Leiche im Keller rum zu liegen.
Unglaubliche.
Aber schön also wie gesagt ich hätte nicht damit gerechnet dass sich diese Situation so dann doch klären lässt.
Wenn man sich diese Scheiße auf deine Aufzeichnung der Landtagsdebatte gibt es gibt natürlich dann da auch so eine AFD.
Vertreter eine ganz andere Meinung vertritt natürlich in dieser Angelegenheit.
Klar wenn das Konzept irgendwie von dem Ex alfreda stammt oder so.
Aber ich hoffe bin erst mal guter Dinge über den über den in Anführungszeichen Etappensieg und hoffe dass jetzt irgendwie auch bei der Polizei Vernunft einkehrt.
Und diese Veranstaltung wie immer friedlich und ohne weitere Vorkommnisse und Störungen über die Bühne gehen kann.
Ja ohne weitere Vorkommnisse und Störung hat ja auch die CDU gehofft
die Europawahl einleiten zu können zumindest die in den Endkampf hier die letzte Woche und das hat auch dieses richtig gut funktioniert komischerweise weil ein findiger Youtuber namens rezo
bereits seit mehreren Wochen offenbar oder Monaten sogar kräftig am recherchieren warum
sogenanntes Zerstörer Video zu produzieren das dann auch erschienen bei dem schönen Titel eben die Zerstörung der CDU dass es dann schon auch glaube ich das erste wo die Öffentlichkeit da so ihre schwierig,
hatte das richtig zu verstehen weil diese zerstörte der Begriff zerstören hat,
in der modernen Netz und insbesondere der Videowelt eben eine spezifische Bedeutung und sollte gar nicht so sehr.
Soll sagen nicht falsch verstanden werden bedeuten tut es nämlich im Wesentlichen ich produziere jetzt hier einen Clip,
ich lege meine Meinung da und damit zerstöre ich in Anführungsstrichen deine Darlegung deiner Meinung von der ich der Auffassung bin dass sie in irgendeiner Form fehlgeleitet oder doch zumindest mangelhaft.
Es hat glaube ich außerdem noch dass es das sehr dass das ja auch doppeldeutig quasi ist weil er darlegt wie die CDU den Planeten und Deutschland zerstört glaube ich so habe ich sie ihnen anfangs.
So kann man das auch lesen.
Stammherr.
Also die Zerstörung durch die CDU sozusagen.
Ich habe da gerade noch mal kurz drauf geschaut das Ding hat inzwischen elf Millionen Views fast so viel wie logbuch-netzpolitik jede Woche Download hat also das ist schon eine.
Hier kommt langsam in unserem Bereich hier.
Ist schon signifikant,
ich finde das so bärenstarker also der macht normalerweise eigentlich eher so ja Entertainment Videos mit Musik.
Soll ich mal eher die Inhalte auf YouTube die ich zu konsumieren selten Zeit finde.
Sing hier ist meine Wohnung und so macht auch glaube ich auch ganz gute Musik netter junger Mann der da jetzt irgendwie,
in dieser uploadfilter Debatte übrigens auch schon einmal sich politisch eingemischt hat mit dem Aufruf anzurufen hätte im Prinzip das gleiche gemacht wie hier die pledge 20910 Kampagne.
Wo er sagte hier ruf dort mal an da sind ja viele
Argumentationen und viele Aktionen tatsächlich in diesen beiden Paralleluniversen YouTube und etablierte Organisationen
gelaufen haben wir ja hier auch alles diskutiert da war er auch alle Mann an vorderster
Front mit dabei auch da schon inhaltlich immer sehr stringent am Argument.
Und ja man kann also hier glaube ich durchaus merken dass.
Die Sache mit den uploadfilter neben für die Youtuber in Anführungszeichen noch lange nicht gegessen ist ja und das mit dem mit dem mit dem Klimawandel auch nicht und
dann hat sich eben hier mal jemand der wahrscheinlich mit seinem YouTube-Kanal inzwischen auch mal die eine oder andere Woche aussetzen kann sich mal die Zeit genommen hier
einen schönen Rundumschlag in zielgruppengerechter Sprache,
vorzutragen und dieses Video ist am laufenden Band schießen da die die Quellenangaben durch ja das ist also man sieht ich will nicht wissen wie viel Arbeiter da reingesteckt hat ja das ist wirklich eine.
Er meinte er hätte wirklich viele Monate dran rum recherchiert.
Völlig völlig völlig klar ne also das ist mal richtig ordentlich und jetzt bin ich aber viel Spanne habe jetzt eh alle gesehen die Reaktionen ja also erstmal die.
Was war denn dein erster Gedanke als du das Video gesehen hast mal ganz unabhängig von der Reaktion der Öffentlichkeit das ging ja bei Twitter dann irgendwie auch schnell rum dann ist der Zeitpunkt wo wir das dann zur Kenntnis nehmen.
Mein erster Eindruck war krass ok das ist echt mal
ja im Prinzip eine fast Neugestaltung des Formates ja zu sagen hier im Anhang ist ein Google Doc da sind alle Beläge
und die sind so krass und so viele dass ich hier immer nur noch kurz die das Kürzel dazu einblende ja und jeder der ist kaum Einsatz den er keine Tatsachenbehauptung die er aufsteht wohl nicht jedesmal Ei
wenn es in Video vorgehalten ist wenn wenn es in Video abrufbar ist spielt das ja auch direkt ein.
Diese so penible ist arbeiten das ist für mich einfach in meiner Wahrnehmung wirklichen auch neu definierend für das Format zweitens.
Weil ich natürlich sehr erfreut weil ich in in der uploadfilter debatten dann doch,
das ein oder andere YouTube Video gesehen habe wo ich dann doch eher so ein bisschen peinlich berührt war was soll ich mal die,
Emotionalität die inhaltliche Fundierung und auch eigentlich die gesamte Vortragsweise in dieser Auseinandersetzung,
dort an ging ja so dass ich jetzt erstmal,
nicht von allen YouTube Videos zum Thema uploadfilter besonders angetan war und hier also in das hat mich dann doch enorm
beeindruckt und enorm gefreut dass hier eine derartige.
Ja also für mich wirklich mag sein dass ich da nicht bei YouTube nicht so offen auf der Höhe der Zeit bin aber für mich wirklich prägend
ja als Ansatz als als Darbietungsformen kann ich kann ich nur nur nur,
gutheißen hat mich sehr sehr gefreut und wenn wenn alles wenn YouTube immer so wäre dann hätte ich würde ich auch sicherlich mehr Zeit finden mir das regelmäßig Anzug.
Habe es nur so angeschaut und zwei Häppchen ich meine für Podcaster in der 55 Minuten eher wie gar nichts aber wenn das halt alles in diesem doch recht heftigen Jump cuts Video Star Schlag auf Schlag auf einen einprasseln dann
wird das so mit der Aufmerksamkeit Kultur schon etwas schwierig habe ich mir mein Ende dann doch,
angeschaut ich fand es erstmal sehr interessant allerdings ohne überheblich klingen zu wollen dass sie mir so als erstes so.
Okay da ist jetzt für mich jetzt nicht viel Neues dabei.
Was ja auch nicht in unserer eigenen Sendung Tim ist vor uns auch nicht viel Neues dabei wenn ich das mal so trocken sagen darf ne also.
Bernard verkehrsreich ist das war doch nur du so meine erste innere Reaktion fand es aber auch sofort gut so nach dem Urlaub dachte mir dann so.
Ist aber gut dass das mal so kohärent in einem Lauf zusammengestellt wird.
Ja also das ist so sauber mal die einzelnen Fakten der weiß glaube ich nichts dabei was mich jetzt so wie komplett
Wecker klingelt hat aber diese Verdichtungen und er hat es ja auch sauber mal ganz in der ganze ordentliche Reihenfolge gestellt die fand ich dann doch schon sehr hilfreich und fragte mich schon die ganze Zeit während ich so das Video sah.
Verpufft das ja,
oder wird das nur so ein Video wo man mal irgendwann mal drauf hinten zeigen kann sagen kannst du ja hier guck mal das irgendwie mal ganz gut zusammen getragen dann muss das jetzt nicht alles noch mal erklären warum man irgendwie
das nicht macht also CUP hin und.
Hab das dann erstmal so ein bisschen beiseite gelegt ich habe da jetzt nicht unmittelbar drauf reagiert weil ich dann nämlich die ganze Zeit letzte Woche war ich dann halt auch unterwegs,
merkte dann aber schon am Rande sodass es
am laufenden Meter wieder in meine Timeline gespült wurde also es kam nicht einmal sonst kann man auf E10 und gefühlte 100 mal spätestens als ich dann noch wie in Stuttgart auf dem Bahnhof Ausstieg und auf so einer großen LED-Leinwand
rezo Video die Diskussion lalala okay alles klar ist scheint jetzt so ein bisschen Welle gemacht zu haben da hat wohl einer schlecht reagiert.
Genau da hat einer schlecht reagiert und zwar die CDU also es war wirklich meine Güte war das peinlich also erstens haben also was sind die die die Konfliktlinien erstens haben,
Eminönü will das ist aber total gemein was Du hier sagst dann kam irgendwie so jetzt jetzt eh wieso haha,
der hat ja gar keine Ahnung ne wir wollen den jetzt wir sollten mit dem diskutieren dann wollen wir mal sehen ob der auf unserem Niveau diskutieren kann Höchstalter
das überhaupt nicht seine Aufgabe mit euch zu diskutieren das ist nicht Youtuber der Macht lustige Musikvideos der hat sich heute mal einen Monat Zeit genommen mal seine Sicht der Dinge mit 20 Bit mit weiß ich 200
1000 belegen darzustellen so und ihr kriegt jetzt mal einen vor dem Mappe ihr habt vier Jahre lang regiert auf EU-Ebene ist der Zyklus glaube ich fünf Jahre so dass ihm auch nicht seine Aufgabe sich euren Fragen zu stellen,
es ist eure Aufgabe sich sein zu stellen und die hat euch jetzt hier mal etwas geliefert.
Aber Dinos Dinos Dinos mit dem Angriff von Amthor wird das alles in Ordnung kommen.
TÜV.
Ja
Amthor konnte nicht genügend Kräfte für ein YouTube-Video mobilisieren.
Die Antwort Antwort ist nicht Erfolg.
Hawkers.
Wo lächerlich also gerade von Konrad Adenauer.
Best Western E28 Stelle.
Da darf aber jemand aus dem Rossmann irgendwie Farbe holen.
Unter take one for the team und wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe haben die den Abenteuer sogar von der Kamera gesetzt.
United dein fertig war hat irgendjemand noch die Notbremse gezogen gesagt hat Haslach.
Keine gute Idee.
Lass gut sein.
Ich glaube nicht das ist immer also ich will mir nicht also ich habe das so verstanden dass du dass es da schon Brot ein Produkt gibt mal schauen ob wir das demnächst dann irgendwie von süddeutsch von Spiegel geleaked kriegen.
Genau Liebe Whistleblower in der CDU ich hätte da eine Bitte.
Dann aber also so die CDU die sich dann da irgendwie,
hätte der der der wir dürfen aber gar nicht drauf antworten natürlich darauf antworten ihr habt den ganzen ihr seid eine Regierung ihr seid eine ganze Partei ihr ihr seid in ein europäischer Verband ihr habt nen YouTube-Kanal ihr habt
1000 Medien zur Auswahl den ihr antworten könnt.
Und jetzt auf einmal kommt so ein kleiner David mit blauen Haaren und ihr steht da mit Hose runter dann scheint der wohl den richtigen Nerv getroffen zu haben.
Fahren die Weiber cdu.tv auf YouTube erstmal damit beschäftigt gerade die ganzen Videos die sie als Urheberrechtsverstöße hochgeladen haben wieder zu löschen also die waren total bissi.
So und dann dann aber muss man jetzt aufhören wird was hat der Typ abgekriegt also erster diese hilflosen Reaktion der telefonieren im diese,
die Sender Anfüttern du hast mir noch gar nicht geantwortet wir wollten uns doch auf deinem Kanal unterhalten oder denkst du oben Mann Alter ihr könnt ihr nicht könnt ihr nicht einfach Wahlwerbung buchen wie jeder andere Partei auch,
müsst ihr jetzt auch noch irgendwie hier diesen diese Namen Youtuber anbetteln man ey das war wirklich nur noch erbärmlich und.
Dann eben diese immer wieder gestreuten Angriffe auf seine angeblich nicht 100-prozentige fak
untreuer ja ja das und das hat er aber verkürzt dargestellt ja schreibt da die Bild-Zeitung ja was der hat etwas verkürzt dargestellt das ist ja ein Skandal,
gut dass die Bild-Zeitung daraus eine Überschrift gemacht hat damit was wissen ja unglaublich.
Ja ja auch die CDU sind ja aber wir zerstören ja nicht 24 Stunden im Planeten wir machen das ja nur 23 Stunden und 35 Minuten und ja.
Am geilsten war irgend so ein Typ der dann da da muss ich auch noch mal gucken wer das war der dann sagt er so hier wieder lege ich die Behauptung von,
von rezo und das erste was er widerlegt ist wieso behauptet Jugendlichen würde die CDU nicht wählen aber auch unter den Jugendlichen sind wir sehr beliebt.
Sag soyder.
Hast du das Video überhaupt geguckt du Spinner weißt du warum sie geht's nicht darum wer Euch wählt und wenn nicht es geht also wirklich sehr sehr unterhaltsam kann ich nur sein.
Am besten fand ich diese CDU-Politikerin die meinte so naja aber habt ihr mal nachgerechnet wie viel Strom dadurch verbraucht wird dass dieses Video so oft angeschaut wird.
Genau.
Ja also da damit ruiniert man ja die Umwelt.
Rätsel Rätsel nicht gucken für für future also wirklich ein ein Niveau wurde der echt denken meine Güte dann sind die ja wirklich so inkompetent wenn die sich.
Mit ein bisschen.
Mit ein bisschen Recherche und ein bisschen Power von einem Spaß Youtuber so unter Druck setzen hast du das natürlich leider nicht was hier wirklich passiert ist was die unter Druck gesetzt hat ist nicht.
Was er.
Gesagt hat das wird ihm ja den ganzen Tag von anderen Leuten auch gesagt was sie unter Druck gesetzt hat ist dass das viral gegangen ist und was sie dann getan haben sie haben ja dann auf ihrer Webseite
cdu.de er ein CDU Positionspapier,
ja ganzes PDF ich weiß nicht 11 Uhr Seiten glaube ich unsere Antworten an rezo veröffentlicht Herr.
Wo ich nur sagen kann offene Antwort an rezo wie wir die Sache sehen ja das ist ein 300 km PDF mit.
Let let let us.
Wie viel Seiten sind haben sie noch nicht mal Seitenzahlen dran wo kann ich das denn jetzt immer anzeigen.
Mal zum Ende scrollen.
Ja aber meint mein Browser zeigt nicht die Seitenzahl also mehrere Seiten und da ist mir etwas.
Aufgefallen ja nun ist es ja nicht so als hätte ich nicht schon mal die CDU in einer Position fundiert,
kritizität sein ist fertig richtig im Kopf ne es ist ja nun wirklich nicht so als würden Mädchen das nicht,
jeden Tag tun es ist nicht so als würden wir das hier in diesem Podcast nicht wöchentlich tun und ich habe
versucht nicht zu erinnern aber ich weiß tatsächlich nicht wie viele Male
ich in Ausschüssen des Deutschen Bundestages als Sachverständiger Kritik geübt habe an Regierungspläne der CDU ich weiß aber dass es fast jedes Mal wenn ich als Sachverständiger da war.
Pläne der CDU kritisiert habe weil die CDU dieses Land eigentlich immer regiert zumindest,
mit Angela Merkel seit was ist sie für serial ist das jetzt 16 oder 20 Jahre oder so
also meine gesamte der die den größeren Teil meiner politischen Tätigkeit habe ich unter einer Bundeskanzlerin abgeleistet und.
Ich habe niemals auch nur eine Entgegnung bekommen,
ich habe niemals auch nur eine Antwort bekommen konnte da jedesmal meine sorgfältig recherchierten sorgfältig zusammengetragen und und begründeten Punkte aus meinem Fachbereich zu Protokoll geben.
Die ein oder andere Frage gestellt bekommen war ja völlig baff als hatte ich auch glaube ich erzählt als ich,
das letzte Mal zum Thema Staatstrojaner im Bundestag war als dann der.
Patrick ittrich die ganze Zeit Sims Sims Aussage Sensburg der ehemalige Vorsitzende des NSA Untersuchungsausschuss der daraus dann irgendwie ein Buch geschrieben hat.
Mir dann eine Frage stellte eine technische Frage der hat mich ja ich war ja so ich war ja völlig durcheinander,
dass ich auf einmal jemand für meine Position interessiert von der CDU ja und die nicht einfach nur ab geperlt ist der war einer der der seltenen Momente ja er hat eine zärtlich die natürlich trotzdem nur angehört und danach gesagt danke.
Hier Ihre Meinung ist wertvoll für uns rufen Sie nicht an wir rufen Sie an Joana
aber hat wenigstens mal selber dafür gesorgt dass ich noch mehr sagen konnte ich habe niemals eine Entgegnung bekommen niemals auch nur ist passiert das auf meine Kritikpunkte im entferntesten eingegangen wurde.
Das ist einfach nicht der Fall und da fragt man sich natürlich schon so tja vielleicht vielleicht vielleicht vielleicht sollte man daneben YouTube Videos machen für junge Leute,
weil da merken sie es auf einmal weil da merken sie auf einmal dass es ihnen weh tut.
Man denkt vielleicht dass in der parlamentarischen Diskussion
die Entscheidung fallen und das ist das hier irgendwo eine Regierung wenn schon nicht aus Experten dann zumindest von Leuten stattfinden würde die daran interessiert sind zielgerichtet und unter Expertenrat,
sinnvolle Gesetze zu erlassen aber gerade unser erstes Thema.
Entschlüsselung von Messenger Diensten zeigt ja dass die sich seit 20 Jahren 30 Jahre ist die Diskussion altom um key Escrow,
nicht belehren lassen und das tun sie auch von in diesem Fall Riso nicht,
da sind wir dann da symbolisieren sie jetzt tagelang bidan die sich an ekelig
ekelig bieten die sich angenehm an diesen Abend Jungen sagen den Grillen war bei Anne Will ja und der arme arme wieso sagt er so also
ich muss einen sagen so ich habe einen
Probleme mit Stottern wenn ich vor größeren Menschenmengen Rede bei mir zu Hause mit der mit der Kamera läuft das gut aber
Personal so einer Situation fühle ich mich nicht gewachsen und das muss er auch nicht niemand muss sich einer Diskussion mit der CDU.
Auf Publikum vor Publikum gewachsen fühlen wo die CDU das erklärte Ziel hat wie das Thomas Jarzombek schrieb er hat sich nachher dafür entschuldigt wir sollten denen mal ordentlich Grillen.
Ja
hat er nachher für die Wortwahl hatte sich nachher entschuldigt aber der Junge ist 26 und hat hier eine hat hier eine ernsthafte saubere geile Arbeit hingelegt und diese ganzen Angriffe auf denen sind wirklich wirklich schwer
schwerst schwerst erbärmlich so du warst aber zu zu zu zu hr2 der Tag.
Da sind für mich hat sich das insofern dann noch positiv entwickelt als dass ich tatsächlich mal als
Interview ganz kurz in einer Sendung von hr2 der Tag richtig eingeladen wurde,
habe allerdings jetzt hier gar nicht inhaltlich was zu der eigentlichen Reso Debatte beigetragen werden wie das immer so ist bei,
hr2 der Tag Mann berichtet sozusagen gesamt kulturell um das Phänomen selber und nicht so sehr jetzt über die News als solche seiner wird halt hinterfragt und der pressiert und auch andere Bereiche angeschaut und sie haben sich halt auf diesen Meinungskampf im
im Netz und also sagen Sie das Phänomen der politischen Diskussion wie sie im Internet sich abbildet geblickt und dann natürlich die News.
Beleuchtet aber daneben auch ein bisschen weiter aufgefaltet
asendia gerade noch mal ganz andere Stellungen und wie ist denn das so interpretiert also noch mal was dazu habe ich was dann dazu gesagt konnte leider nicht live während der Sendung da sein und habe von daher das vorher aufzeichnen müssen,
sodass ich eben nicht gehört hatte was zu dem Zeitpunkt schon von anderen gesagt wurde das ist eigentlich mal ganz hilfreich gewesen weiß aber auch nicht so schlimm und meine Audio Klang auch leider so ein bisschen aus dem Klo weil ich
kann ich im Klo war bei seiner komischen das Kabine weiß,
kurze Zeit später in Flieger gestiegen bin und von daher am Flughafen abhängen und damit ich halt nicht von klappernden geschützt hassen und anderen Einflussnahmen um mich herum,
da akustisch zerstört werde ich mich halt in so eine komische sprechkabine da um dir ein begeben die Klammer etwas merkwürdig von daher nicht so perfekt gelaufen aber ich hoffe ihr inhaltlich was ok.
Tja Tim als ich kann dir nur sagen als ja doch sehr viel reisen reisen da es lohnt sich die kleine Tasche mit dem Beyer dynamic Headset und dem USB-Interface ein Kanal
immer dabei zu haben da ich schon das ein oder andere Mal bei Radiointerviews die Redaktionen mit Entzücken können
das ein oder andere Mal aber auch.
Ja also bei dynamic hättet hätte ich hatte Dich dabei gehabt aber ich musste das leider alles vorher Einchecken von daher fertig.
Und ich muss ich darauf leider auch gerade verzichten das war alles sehr sehr dünn gestrickt.
Der Terminplaner nimmt ach naja egal auf jeden Fall denken wir da auch noch mit drauf wir werden mal schauen was dabei rauskommt das wären wir dann vielleicht oder vielleicht auch nicht an den Europawahl Ergebnissen oder zumindest mal an der Altersverteilung der Stimmen ablesen können und dann schauen wir mal was.
Was ich da aus dem Tesa Zusatz dem Kaffeesatz alles noch so herauslesen lässt.
Ich habe übrigens ich kann nur wärmstens empfehlen,
sich in einer ruhigen Minute mal anzuschauen die rezo Konterrevolution der Vater das ist wirklich Wahnsinn,
die die Frankfurter Allgemeine Zeitung den Typen jetzt hier offenbar zum Abschuss freigegeben hat er kriegst du jetzt in wie heute auf so ein Artikel der ist und ist der erschienen heute morgen
wieso der Geschäftsmann wie Influenza ihr Geld verdienen und wollen jetzt also hier irgendwie
quasi aufdecken er wäre nicht mit Greta Thunberg vergleichbar weil er
Geld hat und wie das überhaupt funktioniert wär's Kopf wieder finanziert ist als Influenza und er ist käuflich und dann gibt's hier noch von anderen.
Wieso Moment versteht her.
Wieso Youtuber kontrolliert gehören oder so ist dann über der till eine Reichweite von dem Mainzer Sender nur träumen können viele Influenza erreichen mehr Menschen als journalistische Formate problematisch wird das wenn sie finanzielle Interessen verfolgen
aber wie authentische Nachbars Jungen von nebenan wirken alter weißt du was problematisch ist,
Wendy Fax politische Interessen verfolgt das ist ein Problem nicht wenn ich bin ein influencer wie der rezo,
App um finanzielle Interessen verfolgt denn in die der wird das einzige Finanzielle Interesse was der daran hat dass dieser Planet nicht an Arsch geht ist das sein Vermögen nicht verbrennt.
Galfer Dissident aus und sind wie der von der fahrzentrum gegen Mitte mit dem Hinweis auf diesen Artikel ja wieder YouTube irgendwie ne weil sie kann wie Formulierung war aber hier so Geld verdienen großes Problem lesen Sie mir jetzt Auffahrt plus.
Hinter der Paywall.
Die merken ist nicht die werden ist.
Ist echt super.
Oje oje.
Ob das der richtige Zeitpunkt ist noch mal auf unsere Shirts hinzuweisen.
Nee wir weisen er daraufhin das nächste Thema passt jetzt zu Geld verdienen also der Geld verdienen möchte.
Edry sucht immer noch einen neuen Head of policy.
Vollzeit Position in Brüssel.
Mit als direkte Report an den executif directors Leiter des,
Erfurt in Brüssel von einem 4 Personen Team das eben von dem Executive Director gemanagt wird.
Setting Meetings und so weiter also wer hier mal richtig strammen Lobbyisten Job in Brüssel.
Annehmen möchte um hier eben gerade jetzt mit der neuen Legislaturperiode,
Netzfreiheit und Bürgerrechte auf dieser Ebene zu arbeiten
er ist gerne eingeladen sich hier zu bewerben bis zum 16. Juni die Deadline wurde verlängert und bitte denkt auch mal darüber nach wenn ihr vielleicht in eurem Bekanntenkreis Wo findet
nicht selten habe ich das festgestellt dass solche Rollen auch erfolgreich mal an,
Quereinsteiger gehen ja sowas wie wir Juristen t.
Vielleicht mal die letzten zehn Jahre als Partner irgendwo ordentlich Geld auf Seite gescheffelt haben und sagen jetzt muss ich mal irgendwie auch noch machen dass das Recht in die richtige Richtung beugen wieder oder.
Irgendwelche anderen erfahrenen Manager die in den Politik Kontext auftreten möchten.
Sehe ich also insbesondere bei bei digitale Gesellschaft aber auch bei anderen Organisation immer wieder so wirklich Quereinsteigerinnen ja die aus anderen Kontexten kommen und sagen okay das ist das.
Klingt spannend natürlich für so eine Rolle wäre es nicht schlecht die Institutionen.
Der Europäischen Union fehlerfrei daher bieten zu können das disqualifiziert mich schonmal aber ich weiß da draußen gibt es eine ganze Menge.
Jura Politik und rechte Mörderinnen und Nerds die vielleicht hier,
ne eine großartige Bereicherung sein könnten denn auch in der neuen Legislaturperiode wird es ja nicht unbedingt einfach und die Arbeit von Erie wird,
immer und immer wichtiger deswegen überlegt nicht nur auf ihr selber vielleicht für diese Rolle in Frage kommt sondern auch wen man da vielleicht aus einer.
Quereinsteiger Rolle vielleicht motivieren.
Guten Tag keine Termine zu verkünden gibt denke ich mal kommerzielles Ende der Sendung hast du noch ein Dankeschön zu verteilen.
Ja ich würde noch gerne dem Rüdiger danken.
Rüdiger sei gedankt ja das war's dann erstmal hier wir hätten ja auch gerne live gesendet dass ihr uns beim Wählen hören könnt.
Darf man aber nicht ne.
Was läuft denn.
Bitte ich war er also selfie aus ist selfie selfie aus der Wahlkampf Kabine geht nicht habe ich weil der mal das Thema ne.
Aber ich werde jetzt mal ich muss da gleich mal rüber gehen.
Und ich weiß auch echt noch gar nicht wen ich wählen werde das ist diesmal total spannend.
Also ich liege gleich habe ich euch das letztens gelesen ich mach das nach dem Ausschlussverfahren.
Zehn kleine Jägermeister und dann denke ich ein paar Jahre zurück und überleg mir so was hat mit dem man nicht gefallen.
Und dann nehme ich nämlich im Zweifelsfall die Partei über die ich mich am wenigsten aufgeregt habe und dich trotzdem kenne.
Wie was ist deine Strategie was war deine Strategie.
Meine Strategie war ich wollte etwas wählen was ganz zweifelsohne proeuropäisch ist.
Und sich nicht zu sehr verkorkst hat bei den Abstimmungen den letzten Jahren und da auf der Seite der Guten stand das war so ein bisschen meine Prämisse.
Basis ist es schwierig mit so einer Europaliste wirkliches an den Kandidaten festzumachen weil man kann ja nicht wirklich für Kandidaten wählen also ich hätte auch gar kein Problem mit einem Wahlsystem wo ich die Möglichkeit hätte speziell Kandidaten zu unterstützen
bei einer Liste.
Schade aber das ist ja nicht gegeben deswegen muss man sich dann schon im Rahmen des modus da auseinandersetzen und da bleibt ja dann halt zurzeit nur die Entscheidung für eine Partei
und ja habe ich mein einer genommen wo ich mit den meisten Persönlichkeiten aus den ersten zehn Plätzen keine Probleme hat zum es keine,
Probleme die sich nicht in irgendeiner Form spricht werden lassen.
Ja
Super dann nächste Woche nächste Sendung können wir dann aussehen wie das ausgegangen ist Europa Krimi.
Werden aber wahrscheinlich auch wieder viele vor uns diskutiert haben wir können dann einfach wäre wie wir fliegen dann die Scherben zusammen.
Genau wird bitte trockne die Tränen das war's bis bald.
Ciao ciao.